Uh,
I became aware of you,
like many people did with the infamous Halloween costume incident at Yale.
Uh,
where,
uh,
explain that for people who don't know what happened cause it was kind of a
crazy scene.
It went national.
Yes,
it was a moment when,
uh,
around the country,
many students were struggling with how to balance a conflicting,
um,
sort of needs a little bit closer,
conflicting needs.
Uh,
uh,
how on the one hand to create an environment in schools where people,
everyone sort of felt welcome as we've democratized,
uh,
admissions to our American universities as I think we should have.
People from all walks of life have started moving into these institutions,
claiming them for their own,
which I think is appropriate.
But at the same time,
these institutions had wonderful heritage is of commitment to free expression
and open debate and,
um,
and reason as a principal for resolving our differences and us and some of those
values came into tension.
And so around the country there was a lot of heat about this.
And I happened to walk into a propeller,
uh,
myself and,
um,
and wound up,
in some challenging circumstances.
And,
um,
you know,
I,
it was not,
it was not the worst thing that's ever happened to me,
but,
you know,
it was in the top 10,
uh,
challenging moments I've had in my life,
let's say.
Yeah,
that's a very lawyer like way of describing exactly what happened.
I mean,
the thing is,
I,
you know,
I struggle.
I mean,
you can tell the story if you want and then I can correct things.
But here's the thing is it's my job to be a teacher and I have taken
responsibility for teaching young people.
And it is the case that many people lost their minds.
I mean,
lost their senses.
And,
and,
and the faculty too,
incidentally,
I mean,
you know,
the,
it's one thing to talk about people in there,
in college age people,
but then,
you know,
the faculty also didn't necessarily do what they should've done,
but,
um,
but the thing is,
is that,
you know,
my commitment,
my commitment is to,
is to teaching more generally.
And I don't want to be defined by that event.
I don't want that to become a,
the most important thing about me.
You know,
I have this book or this book that we're going to talk about that is an
important thing in my life.
Instantiates my values.
It talks about what I think is important about the world.
So,
so I'm trying to be balanced about it.
Just,
it's one thing that happened.
I did my best.
It's in the past.
Let me,
let me help out here because you're being so nice about the whole thing.
Um,
so people know what we're talking about.
There was a,
an incident that was captured on someone's cell phone where you were standing in
people,
it was an hour of footage,
five or six different angles.
So a clip went viral.
But I want to emphasize that there were many people filming that day and an hour
or more of the two or three hours I was out there as available.
But I'm glad that you had the
courage to do that though,
to stand out there and talk to those kids.
But some of them were clearly,
there's something that happens when people become extremely self indulgent when
they know that they have this platform and they,
uh,
have someone who is in a position of authority and they get to hamstring them in
front of the public.
And that's what I felt was going on.
Just my understanding of human nature.
I knew what she was doing,
what she was doing by shouting and screaming,
this is our fucking home.
You know,
uh,
you know,
we were supposed to be safe here.
I was like,
oh,
I see what's going on.
She's throwing up the flag of virtue for all of her friends to see how amazing
she was.
So she's putting on a show.
Uh,
people do that.
It's,
it's,
it's human nature.
You handled it admirably.
You stood there and you,
you just listened to her and you never yelled back and you never raise your
voice and you remain calm.
But that sort of environment where the children,
and I want to say children,
they're basically adults,
but acting like children.
This is one of the ironies of the people that age,
you know,
can fight in wars as lose their lives.
And so I think it's a,
it's a difficult challenge because on the one hand it's right and appropriate to
hold people responsible for their actions.
Certainly if you're 20 years old,
you're an adult,
you're still growing,
you're still changing,
you're still learning.
I'm not the same man I was when I was 20 but you have to be responsible for your
behavior.
Yes.
I don't think you get a total pass either.
It's hard.
No,
you do not get a total pass.
And you know,
for folks who don't have a 20 year old in their life and don't remember what it
was like,
you know,
you're not a fully formed thing yet.
You're,
you're filled with chaos,
emotions and hormones and,
and then you're at school and you're probably away from the instructions of your
parents for the first time and you know,
you're cutting loose and trying out new,
new ways of communicating that way.
It's a lot of,
it's a mess.
But most people felt horrified watching that,
that you were subjected to that when you're being very reasonable.
And also what it all came about was your wife had sent out an email saying like,
hey,
maybe it should be okay for someone to wear a fucked up Halloween costume.
Know.
Maybe it's okay to ask for someone to dress up like crazy horse.
We have,
we'll actually,
just to be clear what Erica was saying in that note,
uh,
was not,
this is very important intellectual distinction.
I think we've,
we've lost a lot of nuance in our political lives in general in our country
right now.
And also in the,
in the nuance,
in the way we think about difficult topics.
So what Erica was saying was not that necessarily the people,
she was not taking a position on any particular costumes like this is okay.
In fact,
many of the costumes that would have offended the students would offend her,
but she was saying was that she didn't think the university should be telling
students what to wear.
And she was asking,
the students,
do use students really at this age at Yale,
do you really want the university to be sending you guidance on what to wear at?
Perhaps you should think about that.
You're adults,
you're smart,
you're in an environment that privileges free expression.
Do you really want to grant the power to an institution to tell you how to
communicate?
And people then a thought that she was saying that,
uh,
that she was defending a particular course of action.
What she was saying was,
um,
you,
uh,
she was saying,
do you students really want to surrender that kind of control over your own
lives to older adults?
And apparently many students did actually they wanted dated.
So I don't believe they did.
I think they wanted absolute enforcement of what they thought to be wrong or
right.
Yes,
yes.
I think that's right.
So they,
they,
uh,
they did the many,
but not all of the students.
I mean,
let's be,
let's also be very clear.
And in part of the motivation in,
in Erica a writing that note was that,
uh,
many,
many of her students and in fact many hundreds of other students felt
infantilized by this policy.
And there had been a big build up prior to that event,
including an article in the New York Times about these Halloween costume
policies around the country.
And weren't they kind of ridiculous.
And so there was a,
there was a kind of a,
a ferment where people were saying,
wait a minute,
do we really need adults to be told in this institution,
especially given its commitments to open expression,
uh,
what to wear?
And keep in mind that there could be many ways in which a costume that offends
you might not,
might,
I might not know why.
So let's say you had been abused by a priest and you were,
uh,
that one of the rules said you shouldn't emoc religion,
for example,
was what one of the Pr,
one of the provisions.
So,
so a,
a university wide email went out,
signed by 13 people saying,
um,
you know,
don't,
uh,
don't mock people's deeply held faith traditions.
Well,
what if for the sake of argument,
you had been a,
uh,
abused by a priest and you want it did Halloween to dress up as a Catholic
priest,
for example.
Uh,
you know,
holding a doll and someone else who had a different,
who was Catholic was very deeply offended by that.
Well,
who should adjudicate that?
Like,
you know,
is it the role of the institution to come down and say,
yes,
you can express yourself this way?
No,
you cannot.
And so the argument was,
let the young people learn,
let them sort it out themselves.
Let them learn by talking to each other,
expressing themselves,
saying,
you know,
that hurts my feelings.
Here's why it hurts my feelings.
And the other person say,
oh,
I understand,
or I don't understand.
I reject that reason.
And,
and sort of buy into a kind of commitment to free and open expression that
actually I think ultimately serves the objectives of righteous social progress.
If we really want to do better in our society or in any society in my view,
we have to create an environment where we can talk to each other,
grant,
good faith,
uh,
listen carefully,
make subtle distinctions and,
and free people up to express what they're thinking so we can have a real
marketplace of ideas.
That's,
you know,
my commitment or my belief.
Well that's a wonderful belief.
11,
I mean that's really a,
I couldn't agree with you more,
more enthusiastically.
That's really,
that sounds like the best possible environment for growing up and learning as
long as you have someone to sort of moderate or someone to mediate if things go
sideways.
Yes.
Or I don't think you necessarily need a third party mediator,
but you do need a shared understanding of,
of a core liberal principles.
And these principles do include,
as I mentioned earlier,
I kind of commitment to free and open expression,
a commitment to debate,
a commitment to reason.
So how are you and I going to come to a better understanding of what is true
about the world we could fight,
right?
And then the,
the stronger person would decide what's right.
We could vote.
Doesn't seem quite right either.
You know,
350 cardinals voted that Galileo was wrong.
That didn't make Galileo wrong.
Or we could use principles of reason and inquiry to try to appreciate the world
together.
Right?
We're looking at at the world and saying,
that's confusing.
You know,
does the sun,
does the earth revolve around the sun or does the sun revolve around the earth?
Or that's confusing.
Should a king have monarch,
you know,
should a king of ultimate authority in a state or is that not how we want to
organize a state?
So we,
you and I look at the world and debate and think about,
okay,
and we exchange reasons and we use evidence and ways of understanding and
studying the world.
That to me is the only way to truth.
Actually.
Now,
some people will think that religion is a way to truth,
right?
They think that the truth is,
you know,
has god given.
For example,
now I am very sympathetic to religious belief systems,
but I don't think that's a way to truth that it's a way to,
some truths actually it's a way to some some wisdom,
but anyway,
so that's what our universities in our society,
our universities are officially committed to that the mottos of our universities
are all about free inquiry and pursuit of knowledge and our country is committed
to that in our bill of rights,
right?
We have a commitment to free and open expression,
freedom of assembly,
freedom of religion and so forth and,
and those ground rules then in my view,
make it possible for us to have a better society and,
and there's
more academic.
Well,
I'm sure we will get into it.
No,
I'm sure we will.
Again,
I couldn't agree with you more enthusiastically.
I just think we need more reasonable conversations in this screaming and
shouting people down and less toxic mob action.
Yes.
The mob action is very weird because I don't remember it well from the like from
the Vietnam war
protests to what's going on today.
There was this long gap where you didn't hear about university shutting down
speech.
Yes.
This is fairly new.
This is within the last half decade or so.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
I mean they're always there.
There's always an undercurrent of tension about this at,
at universities and in our society at large.
Uh,
I mean let's not forget the McCarthy era where you had the right wing was,
you know,
really interested in shutting down communists.
Like if you were a professor or an artist who had far left political views,
you were screwed.
Yes.
And that's what's wrong.
Or even if you'd want went to a communist meeting yes.
Find out what it was all about.
Yes.
Just to educate yourself.
In fact,
that's a great example because that,
like right now I see a lot of people being criticized for following online
people they disagree with,
which is nuts.
Crazy.
So I just,
because I follow someone doesn't mean I agree with what they're saying.
I'm interested to learn.
What are they saying?
I'm friends with people.
I don't agree with me too.
I am friends with so many people that don't agree with.
I have a friend.
I have,
I have friends across the political spectrum from the,
I don't have any monarchists among my friends who are Monica,
but I have friends from the far right to far left.
I have a friend who really believes you sold libertarian.
He thinks there should be private ownership of roads.
Uh,
whoa.
Yeah.
I mean,
yeah,
I think that's ridiculous.
And we debate,
but he must be white.
He's actually
my wife.
My wife says she'll just once like to meet a poor libertarian female
libertarian.
Yes.
No.
Um,
yeah.
That's a ridiculous position.
I think.
So.
Private roads get the fuck out of here.